Transcription: Pauline Seguinot
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Mesdames et messieurs, bonsoir !
Malgré mon grand sourire, je vais
vous annoncer une nouvelle terrible.
Le bonheur au travail n’existe pas.
Je dirais même plus,
le bonheur au travail
est une vaste supercherie.
C'est dommage.
C'était une belle idée.
Arriver à combiner
le bonheur, la plénitude,
ce sentiment de satisfaction totale
avec le travail qui est souvent
caractérisé par son étymologie :
le trepalium, l'instrument de torture.
Arriver à combiner ces deux éléments,
c'était un très, très beau projet.
Et pourtant,
quand on s'y intéresse vraiment
on se rend compte que,
on est quand même sur...
- n'ayons pas peur des mots -
sur une vraie fumisterie.
Je vais m'expliquer.
Si on s'intéresse un peu
à la santé mentale au travail
on se rend compte que certains concepts
sont apparus depuis quelques années.
Avant les années 90, on n'en parlait pas.
Être stressé au travail,
c'était une hérésie.
Ensuite est apparu
le concept de harcèlement au travail,
suite à l’ouvrage de
Marie-France Hirigoyen :
« Le harcèlement moral au travail ».
On a commencé à parler
un peu de ces travaux-là.
Ensuite, plusieurs concepts sont apparus :
Le stress, la souffrance au travail,
les risques psychosociaux :
le fameux RPS,
notamment suite aux événements,
on va les appeler comme ça,
chez France Télécom.
On a commencé à parler
de plus en plus de ces éléments-là.
Pour qu'au détour des années 2010,
on a commencé à voir
le verre à moitié plein.
Bien-être,
qualité de vie au travail QVT,
et enfin,
ce fameux bonheur au travail.
Quand on creuse un peu,
encore un peu plus,
Qu'est-ce que l'on met derrière
ce bonheur au travail ?
Des baby-foot ?
Des tables de ping-pong ?
Parfois on va repeindre certains murs ?
Mettre des poufs, des fauteuils de
plusieurs couleurs dans les entreprises ?
Parfois même on désigne
un Chief Happiness Officer.
Peut-être que certains l'entendent ?
Responsable du bonheur au travail.
Je ne sais pas vous,
mais, moi, je l'imagine comme ça :
Soyez heureux !
Pourtant, ces entreprises
qui ont développé
cette politique de bonheur au travail,
encore une fois
qui est super prometteuse.
Quand on s’intéresse un peu,
quand on regarde
les différents indicateurs classiques :
accidents du travail, arrêt de travail,
taux d'absentéisme, taux de turn-over,
les indicateurs sont toujours aussi...
compliqués. (il rit)
On ne note pas réellement
d’amélioration de ces indicateurs
dans ces entreprises qui se vantent,
qui communiquent sur le fait de réaliser
une politique de bonheur au travail.
Et quand on continue encore
à s’y intéresser, à creuser,
en tant que chercheur qui se respecte,
quand on continue à creuser,
on se rend compte que
même certaines conséquences
peuvent être encore plus délétères.
Parfois même, le bonheur
peut créer le malheur.
Parfois même le fait de développer
une politique de bonheur au travail
est une stratégie,
une injonction au bonheur,
comme je l'ai dit :
Soyez heureux !
Ce qui amène à la idée que
si vous n'êtes pas heureux
l'entreprise a quand même
tout mis en œuvre
pour que vous soyez heureux.
Si vous n’êtes pas heureux,
c'est de votre faute.
Si vous n’êtes pas heureux
avec ce baby-foot,
cette table de ping-pong,
avec ces murs de toutes les couleurs,
avec cette politique
de bonheur au travail,
c'est de votre faute.
Et donc on voit
toute la dimension stratégique,
toute cette réalité derrière ce concept,
encore une fois très prometteur,
de bonheur au travail.
Mais également il y a évidemment
cette dimension de communication.
Apparaissez
le plus haut dans les fameux classements
« Great Places to Work ».
Vous connaissez ces classements ?
Ces classements des best workplaces :
les entreprises où il fait bon vivre.
Quand on s’intéresse un peu
à ces classements,
quand on regarde
quelles sont les entreprises,
je ne vais pas les citer,
on ne sait jamais.
Mais le classement est disponible.
Quand on regarde
ces classements,
quand on regarde les entreprises
qui sont dans les 15 premiers,
on se rend compte
qu'il y a des entreprises
qui ne sont pas forcément réputées
comme étant des entreprises
qui défendent absolument
la place de l’être humain
dans l’organisation.
On va formuler ça comme ça.
Quand on s'intéresse à la manière dont
est constitué ce classement,
tout d'abord, c'est du déclaratif :
les entreprises elles-mêmes déclarent.
Ensuite il y a quelques experts
qui se mobilisent, mais bon...
Et surtout ça met en évidence
un phénomène que nous avons choisi
avec mon co-auteur,
Jean-Christophe Vuattoux,
de l’Université de Poitiers.
On a proposé un concept
qui s'appelle le « Great Washing ».
Peut-être que ça fait écho
à un concept existant ?
Le Green Washing ?
Vous connaissez ce concept ?
Le concept de Green Washing
qui voudrait que
des entreprises communiquent
sur le fait de respecter l'environnement,
de développer des pratiques
en lien avec l'écologie,
et que dans les faits,
la réalité soit beaucoup moins reluisante.
Bien, nous avons souhaité proposer
un concept qui reprenait cette structure,
enfin, cette forme de Great Washing
où les entreprises développent
une communication fantastique
autour de la santé au travail
et du bonheur au travail.
Et quand on creuse encore une fois
sur les pratiques réelles,
et sur la manière dont
ça se passe dans l'entreprise
on se rend compte que
l'écart est de plus en plus important.
Et donc, l'important,
au-delà du bonheur au travail,
au-delà même de la QVT, du bien-être, etc.
Revenons à l'essentiel.
Revenons à l'analyse, à l’étude,
à la mise en débats
de l'activité du travail.
Souvent les ergonomes
appellent ça le travail réel.
C'est à dire la manière dont
le travail se passe réellement,
toutes les difficultés que vous avez
dans votre activité-travail,
dans sa réalisation,
toutes ces contradictions,
tous ces éléments que
l'on n'arrive pas forcement à anticiper
en étant trop éloigné
de la réalité du travail.
Reparlons du travail dans l’entreprise.
De plus en plus on voit émerger,
et c'est très bien,
des espaces de discussions qui ont
pour objectif de débattre du travail,
de débattre de l'activité-travail.
Non pas de passer par
des artifices managériaux,
parce que le bonheur au travail
est un artifice managérial.
Non pas de repasser par là,
mais de remettre l’activité-travail
au sein des discussions,
de reparler dans l'entreprise.
On se rend compte que,
à l'ère de la communication
on ne communique plus dans l’entreprise.
Reparler du travail, re-débattre,
remettre le sens au travail
et le sens du travail
au cœur de la réflexion,
c’est ce qui est prioritaire.
Et une fois que l’on aura fait tout cela,
peut-être que l’on pourra se permettre
une petite partie de baby.
Là, on pourra se le permettre.
Je vous remercie de votre attention.
(Applaudissements)